Plus d'un million de personnes sont tuées chaque année dans des catastrophes.
2,5 millions garderont des séquelles ou seront déplacées
et les communautés mettront 20 à 30 ans à s'en remettre
sans compter les milliards en pertes financières.
Si on pouvait réduire d'un jour la phase des premiers secours,
on pourrait réduire la reconstruction entière
d'un millier de jours, soit 3 ans.
Pourquoi cela ?
Si les premiers secours peuvent accéder, sauver des vies,
parer à un risque d'inondation,
alors d'autres équipes peuvent accéder
pour rétablir l'eau, les routes, l'électricité,
puis les équipes de construction, les agents d'assurance,
tous peuvent commencer à reconstruire les maisons,
ce qui signifie veut dire que vous pouvez restaurer l'économie,
et peut-être même l'améliorer et la rendre plus résistante au prochain désastre.
Une grande compagnie d'assurance m'a dit
que s'ils peuvent traiter le dossier d'un propriétaire un jour plus tôt,
cela améliorera de 6 mois le delai
pour réparer sa maison.
Voilà pourquoi je m'occupe de robotique de secours
parce que les robots peuvent accélérer le retour à la normale.
Vous en avez déjà vu quelques exemples.
Je veux parler des drones.
Il y en a 2 sortes :
à rotor, ou colibri,
à aile fixe, ou faucon.
Et ils sont beaucoup utilisés depuis l'ouragan Katrina, en 2005.
Je vais vous montrer comment marche ce drone colibri.
Fantastique pour les ingénieurs en structures.
Être capable de voir les dommages d'un autre angle que depuis le sol
ou sur une image satellite,
ou de n'importe quoi volant plus haut.
Mais ce n'est pas utile que pour les ingénieurs et les assureurs.
Vous avez ce drone à aile fixe, ce faucon.
Il peut être utilisé pour des études géo-spatiales.
Lorsque vous combinez les images ensemble
pour créer des reconstitutions en 3D.
Nous les avons utilisés lors des glissements de terrain à Oso,
car le problème majeur
était la compréhension géospatiale et hydrologique du désastre --
pas le sauvetage.
Les équipes de secours contrôlaient la situation
et savaient quoi faire.
Le risque principal était que la rivière et la coulée de boue emportent
et engloutissent les secours.
Et ce n'était pas risqué seulement pour les secours et les habitations,
mais aussi pour le futur de la pêche au saumon
dans l’État de Washington.
Ils avaient besoin de comprendre ce qui ce passait.
En 7 heures, ils ont pu rouler d'Arlington
jusqu'au PC de crise, puis au site, faire décoller les drones,
traiter les données, et revenir au poste de commandement d'Arlington --
sept heures.
Nous leur avons fourni en 7 heures les données qu'ils auraient mis
2 à 3 jours à obtenir autrement --
et avec une meilleure précision.
C'est un changement radical.
Et il n'y a pas que les drones.
D'accord, ils sont sexy -- mais rappelez-vous que
80% de la population mondiale vit à côté de l'eau,
donc une part essentielle de notre infrastructure
peut être sous l'eau, inaccessible, par exemple les ponts.
Et c'est pourquoi nous avons des drones sous-marins,
dont vous connaissez déjà un spécimen, SARbot, un dauphin cubique.
Il va sous l'eau et utilise un sonar.
Pourquoi les robots marins sont si importants,
et pourquoi sont-ils très très importants ?
On les oublie.
Prenez le tsunami au Japon --
650 km de côtes totalement dévastées,
deux fois l'étendue ravagée par Katrina aux États-Unis.
Il s'agit des ponts, des pipelines, des ports -- rasés.
Et si vous n'avez pas de port,
vous n'avez pas de moyen d'envoyer assez d'aide humanitaire
pour aider la population.
C'était un problème majeur lors du tremblement de terre en Haïti.
Donc nous avons besoin des robots marins.
Maintenant regardons grâce à SARbot
ce qu'ils voyaient.
Nous travaillions dans un port de pêche.
Nous avons pu ré-ouvrir ce port de pêche, en utilisant son sonar, en 4 heures.
On leur avait dit que ça allait prendre 6 mois
avant de pouvoir envoyer une équipe de plongeurs sur place,
et que ça allait prendre 2 semaines aux plongeurs.
Trop tard pour la saison automnale de pêche,
ce qui représentait le plus gros de leurs revenus, c'est comme leur Cape Cod.
Drones sous-marins, très important.
Mais vous voyez, tous les robots que je vous ai montrés sont petits,
et c'est parce qu'ils ne font pas ce que les personnes font.
Ils vont là où personne ne peut aller.
Un bel exemple en est Bujold.
Les drones terrestres sont particulièrement petits,
comme Bujold --
(Rires)
Dites bonjour à Bujold.
Bujold fut beaucoup utilisé au World Trade Center
pour explorer les tours 1, 2 et 3.
Vous escaladez les décombres, descendez dans les cavités en profondeur.
Regardez à quoi le World Trade Center ressemblait, vu de Bujold.
C'est un désastre sur lequel ni humain ni chien ne pouvaient intervenir --
et c'est en feu.
Le seul espoir d'atteindre un survivant dans le sous-sol,
est de traverser des débris en flammes.
Il faisait si chaud que sur un des robots, les chenilles commençaient à fondre.
Les robots ne remplacent pas les gens ni les chiens,
ni les colibris, les faucons ou les dauphins.
Ils réalisent des choses nouvelles.
Ils aident les secours, les experts, de façon innovante.
Le plus gros problème n'est toutefois pas de faire des robots plus petits.
Ça ne les rend pas plus résistants à la chaleur.
Ça ne fait pas plus de capteurs.
Le plus gros problème, ce sont les données, l'informatique,
car ces gens ont besoin de la bonne donnée au bon moment.
Ne serait-ce pas fabuleux si les experts pouvaient accéder directement aux robots,
sans perdre de temps à se rendre sur site,
et utiliser les robots via Internet ?
Imaginons le cas
du déraillement d'un train de produits chimiques dans la campagne.
Quelles sont les chances pour que les experts, vos chimistes,
vos ingénieurs ferroviaires,
aient été formés sur le type de drone disponible à cet endroit ?
Probablement aucune.
Donc nous utilisons ces interfaces
pour permettre aux gens d'utiliser ces robots sans les connaître,
ou même sans savoir s'ils utilisent un robot ou pas.
Ce que les robots fournissent, ce qu'ils offrent aux experts, ce sont des données.
Le problème devient : qui reçoit quelle donnée et quand ?
Une chose à faire est d'envoyer les données à tout le monde
et les laisser les exploiter.
Mais le problème avec ça, c'est que ça sature les réseaux,
pire, ça sature les capacités d'acquisition
de chaque personne essayant de trouver LE morceau d'information
qui leur permettra de prendre la décision qui fera la différence.
Donc nous devons réfléchir à ce genre de problèmes.
Voilà pour les données.
Revenons au World Trade Center,
on a essayé de résoudre ce problème en enregistrant les données de Bujold
juste quand il était au fond des décombres,
parce que c'est ce que les secours disaient vouloir.
Ce qu'on ignorait alors,
c'est que les ingénieurs en génie civil auraient bien aimé,
qu'on enregistre aussi les poutres, les numéros de série,
les emplacements, sur le chemin dans les décombres.
Nous avons perdu des données utiles.
Donc le défi est de collecter toutes les données
et de les fournir aux bonnes personnes.
Il y a une autre raison.
Nous avons appris que certains bâtiments --
comme les écoles, les hôpitaux, les mairies --
sont inspectés à quatre reprises par différentes agences
au cours des phases d'intervention.
Donc si on a un moyen de partager les données des robots,
on peut non seulement réduire la séquence des différentes phases
pour réduire le temps de réponse,
mais aussi commencer à travailler en parallèle.
Tout le monde peut voir les données.
On peut donc réduire le délai.
En fait, « robotique de premiers secours » est un mauvais nom.
Il ne s'agit pas des robots.
Il s'agit des données.
(Applaudissements)
Voilà donc le défi que je vous lance :
quand vous entendrez parler d'une catastrophe,
cherchez les robots.
Ils peuvent être sous terre, ils peuvent être sous l'eau,
ils peuvent être dans le ciel,
mais ils devraient être là.
Cherchez les robots,
parce que les robots viennent nous sauver.
(Applaudissements)